it's the beautiful Gracie
[Applause]
Abrams I'm like
sweating can I hug you
[Applause]
hi oh it's going to say welcome
to welcome to I'm like I literally you
no you're such an icon it's like nuts to
be this close to you well I should say
the same about you I mean how are you
feeling with everything in your life
thriving so much right now I feel so
absurdly lucky um I just feel so lucky
to be here with you Grammy nominated
though like and opening and singing with
Taylor Swift you
know I mean what
what does it feel like when you get that
call you've been nominated for a Grammy
and not an obscure category Best New
Artist what does it feel like it's it's
such a Trippy honor and it feels like a
fever dream and it hasn't quite landed
but I'm just the biggest fan of everyone
who's in the category that I for some
reason am like I feel like I'm crashing
the party a little bit you know what I
mean no and I'm so Greatful that answer
it's so like human humble normal that's
that's a great answer it's like yeah it
is a little of like wait what's
happening yay whoo it's strange but it's
so lucky and I yeah like what's it like
when Taylor Swift calls and you guys
seem to be very lovely and chummy with
each other like oh my God what what is
that feeling like I
mean whoa um she's like a superhero of a
person and of a friend it's like this
wild thing I think like what I have
known about her being such a super fan
forever is like um she's got this
insane way of speaking to the corners of
our lives and kind of like the
Heartbreak and the best friendship and
the Nostalgia and the homesickness all
these things that we all experience like
frustrated and screwed over everything
um and she shows up for the people in
her life in the way that like she has
shown up so spectacularly for she does
seem like a very good friend she the
most generous person it's like I mean
it's like you talk about someone who
like
oh what song are you singing there there
were singing my song called I miss you
I'm sorry um which was a whole
trippy that song about out of curiosity
song about a breakup um that song's
about a
[Music]
breakup